i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but it is important just to follow
up with some of these things you might
remember that when cassidy hutchinson
um the
uh um who worked with mark meadows
trump's former chief of staff when
cassidy hutchinson testified before the
january 6 committee and made a number of
different explosive claims about donald
trump and secret service and all these
different things there were anecdotally
messages statements from secret service
saying that's not true and we're willing
to testify under oath and the january 6
committee said great come in and testify
under oath and then they didn't why
haven't they done it well
uh we have to sort of speculate a little
bit but here is adam kinzinger one of
the few republicans on the january 6
committee saying
we haven't been able to talk to them i
mean listen they they said
they said we'll talk to you and they
just don't come in um so we want answers
to that uh we heard through anonymous
sources in the media that the secret
service agents you know present when uh
cassidy hutchinson talked about the
heated argument in the the limo the
president's beast uh that they were
eager to talk to us we haven't been able
to talk to them yet either uh we have
our doors wide open they just have to do
it under oath so that on top of again
we just have a lot of people coming
forward with pieces of the puzzle maybe
pieces of information maybe cassidy
hutchison or sarah matthews inspired
them
and so we're going to work on beginning
to write our report but keep this
investigation wide open and getting more
and more information so listen they all
came forward a bunch of them came
forward and they said we're willing to
testify secret service agent reportedly
willing to testify trump did not lunge
at him this is from the guardian and
this was right after the testimony of
cassidy hutchinson and then a bunch of
different other media outlets reported
on this cnn and other outlets reported
the pushback on the alleged secret
service incident from tony ornato also a
deputy chief of staff in the trump white
house robert engel trump's security
chief and on and on and on
and the committee members said we
welcome you to be here under oath of
course and but really cassidy hutchinson
was under oath
what is the value of secret service
agents showing up not under oath and
refuting the claims let's get everybody
under oath so then we can actually say
we have conflicting under oath
statements we continue to have
only one set of claims made under oath
and of course it wasn't surprising to me
i've been tweeting about it for weeks
they haven't testified why haven't they
testified we don't know
um
their law enforcement one would think
they don't have an issue in principle
with being under oath
but if you won't testify under oath
about the things you saw while working
for the secret service to me that's a
red flag and of course in courts of law
we don't consider people silence as
indicative of guilt but when you come
out and you say we'll testify we'll talk
about it we didn't see what cassidy
hutchinson said and then you're welcomed
great show up take an oath just like she
did and tell us what you saw and then
they're missing it is completely
reasonable in the court of public
opinion to say
maybe they weren't telling the truth and
maybe cassidy hutchinson is one other
note on the cassidy hutchinson testimony
um
the former white house counsel
uh in his under oath testimony
he didn't dispute the things that
cassidy hutchinson said
with some he claimed privilege attorney
client privilege with donald trump with
some he did a sort of i don't recall or
i can't necessarily speak to that but
he went under oath and didn't refute any
of the things that cassidy hutchinson
said so still waiting for the secret
service agents to come in
not surprising that they haven't and i
don't expect them to follow me on
twitter at dpakman let me know what you
make of the latest absence of secret
service agents who were just weeks ago
so ready to testify
one of our sponsors is imme
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes emmy
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
plant-based with 18 grams of fiber for
digestive health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen emmy comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp and black garlic chicken
if you try me and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below